well democrats obsession with propping
up failure doesn't end with election
laws
their 1.9 trillion dollar quote relief
bill
bails out wildly irresponsible blue
states and cities including
of course pelosi's hometown of san
francisco the chronicle reporting that
the federal stimulus package will erase
the majority
of san francisco's projected 650
million dollar budget deficit over the
next two years
saving city hall from having to make
painful service cuts and layoffs
so what this really means is that the
old nan's pals running san francisco
will be spared the pain of getting
booted from office
for their complete incompetence joining
me now is house minority leader kevin
mccarthy congressman
this is really rewarding failure
across the board it's not so much of
helping
vulnerable people as helping vulnerable
politicians
no it is actually it rewards bad
behavior
it's a bay area bailout think about that
san francisco has a 650
million dollar deficit and they're
getting 600 million dollars
what does san francisco spend part of
their money on
putting homeless in hotels paying for
their alcohol
paying for their marijuana this bill
also
you know what it does it gives federal
employees
up to twenty one thousand dollars paid
leave they've never been laid off
state employees can get up to twenty
five thousand dollar
bonuses it takes care of the swamp it
goes in and it adds money to pay for the
health care of illegals
and remember they try to say this
happens to deal with covet
less than nine percent of this bill does
anything
for covid and it rewards the states that
we're bad behavior
it literally changes the funding
mechanism
for states getting money in america it
rewards states that
shut down reward states that have
pension problems
instead of a fair process throughout the
nation
well i want to i want to play something
we're going to go back to nancy pelosi
here because
she was asked about whether there would
be more
uh bills like this covered bill
uh that means more trillion dollar type
uh
pieces of legislation congressman and
this is how it went down watch
do you think this is the last primarily
coveted bill that you'll have to take up
you're just going to have to ask the
virus if it stops mutating
if it stops spreading and therefore
mutating then
just we'll just see where we are then
but it's not anything anybody can
predict it's just a question
of the science uh congressman my breath
is taken away
no she's saying it depends on the
viruses mutations she doesn't know
anything about immunology obviously
she doesn't know anything about the fact
that the virus is is clearly
less lethal than it was a year ago but
she's leaving the door open
to more spending meaning the states can
stay locked down meaning the fall can be
closed for kids schooling
would you expect any answer from any
other socialist
it's what margaret thatcher said you
will eventually run out of everybody
else's money and that's what's happening
with this
1.9 trillion this money does nothing to
put people back to work
back to school or back to health it uses
it
to reward those that they care most
about
the mismanagement of states across this
nation to reward federal employees who
have not been laid off give them twenty
one thousand dollars or state employees
a twenty five thousand dollar bonus
that is hard working taxpayers money it
is costing
every family more than five thousand
dollars and a few people will get a
fourteen hundred dollar check
it's one of those crazy emails you get
from another nation it's stupid
congressman it seems like they think
they can buy off the voters in 2022.
that's what it seems like if they spend
enough they print enough money borrow
enough from japan or china or
or wherever borrowing it from these days
or just printing it they'll be able to
buy
buy voters off are you worried that
people are going to get
used to being sadly on the federal dole
i'm concerned about it because what
we're finding today by continuing to
to pay more for people who are
unemployed and not giving them incentive
to go back to work
you find this time and again where's the
accountability where's the work
incentive to get people working again
that's what we'd like to see going
forward but again the democrats find no
other way than to provide
checks out and i'm concerned about that
but i trust the american public
that we rather work than have a
government just pay us we rather have a
better future
and we rather not sacrifice our
children's and grandchildren's futures
for our wasting of money today
congressman
looks like two more months of razor wire
and national guard troops
around the capitol anything we can do to
shut that down or we just
that's going to depend on the viruses
mutation as well
no it should not there there is no
threat i mean
think of the hypocrisy that is the
hypocrisy wall they will not protect the
border they want to take a wall down
around the border but they want to put a
wall around the people's house
that national guard do you know if the
national guard sitting out there sees
somebody climbing the wall
they can't do anything they have to call
the capitol police get a copy they won't
even let people into the capitol
that wall needs to come down the people
need to be invited back in
and we need to protect our borders and
let the people get back to work and back
to school
congressman there's your there's your
campaign ad madam speaker tear down this
wall
great to see you tonight thanks